then is that distributed evenly amongst
people the ability to be creative seems
like so many are trapped in the economic
and political machine well yeah I mean
look if you're hungry you can't be too
concerned about meaning if you've got to
pay the bills you got to pay the bills
but that goes back to the whole Abraham
Maslow and his hierarchy of needs I mean
all these questions of cosmological
significance
Aurra luxury at the end of the day
because it assumes that you were able to
feed yourself for breakfast and that
you're not dying of some horrific
physical ailment I mean certainly I
think in some ways that's why certain
parts of the world maybe that are less
wealthy actually report higher
incidences of life satisfaction and some
bizarre way and it's because you know
like you busy doing your thing going to
work and you don't have time to ask
these profound questions so certainly
don't have the toxicity of some of the
other things yeah but the point is I
think these questions are only going to
become more relevant because
technological advances and and
development across the world continues
to pull hundreds of millions of people
over to poverty all the time there's the
best emerging global middle class that
is becoming more aspirational and thus
is more concerned with with meaning or
increasingly will be in an eventual
happens when you get all the money what
happens when you get the one you love
then you realize that's it you know the
game is over
actually Jordan Peterson talks about
that really brilliantly he talks about
the importance of the noble aim and this
is something that really resonated with
me
he says the noble aim is something that
you want to move towards and you want to
organize your life around but you attain
it because if you attain it the game is
over that's the problem you want to be
moving towards it and always have it
just beyond your grasp
so that it Orient's you and it gives you
a map of meaning and it gives you a sort
of purpose and an orientation and a
compass so to speak but you know life is
not in getting what you want
life is about fighting for meaning and
it's a lesson that we seem to be
learning over and over and over again
and you got that toy in the toy store
you graduated from middle school
when you got that degree you got the job
you got the car it doesn't say she ate
us you know then these are short-term
goals and then we get to the next goal
maybe whatever the long-term goal ends
up being it is to continuously be
creative in the world so maybe things
like yeah automation and AI whatever
ends up happening in the future will
enable more people to be creative over
time well the problem of meaning is not
going away right I think you have I've
read some reports they're like really
developed societies like in Scandinavia
and all these places where socioeconomic
anxiety is minimal and people it's very
yellow tearing society and people have
most of what they want they have all
these social cushions but nonetheless
the problem of suicide and all this kind
of stuff is really [ __ ] up and I think
that the probably meaning is gonna be
more and more even as we become
wealthier as a society potentially and
you know the guy eval
no Harare yeah he wrote sapiens and
homeless day is literally the best book
he says how he throat an article about
finding meaning in life in an age
without work you know because his
prediction is that our worst fears about
technological automation robbing us of
our jobs but also of our life purpose
and meaning is a very real thing
and now the on the optimistic front yes
increasing advances exponential advances
in technology and artificial
intelligence and all these things will
eventually create a world where people
people don't have to work where the AIS
will be able to take care of most of
what everybody means but it's gonna
leave all this empty space in people's
lives and so what are we gonna do to
fill that space you know and he says
that we're actually gonna probably fill
that space in video games virtual
reality virtual realities yeah and but
here's the thing here's the thing he
says that we already give meaning to our
lives with virtual realities such as
culture identity religion you know your
name I mean these are these are not
biological truths these are cultural
virtual realities and nonetheless we use
them to fill our lives with meaning and
purpose supposedly so he predicts that
in the future virtual reality systems
will be full
indistinguishable from the real and we
will be able to lose ourselves in those
worlds and undergo the kind of
mythological heroes journeys that Joseph
Campbell vividly writes about or that
our favorite films beautifully map out I
mean wouldn't you want to be neo in the
matrix and [ __ ] rock it out or ever
like I mean I think that you're in an
80-year one right now I'm in Oh what
you're in an 80-year virtual reality
experiment right now potentially if this
is all a simulation as your event
postulates but then you get to design
your own virtual worlds and you get to
tweak and play with the different
variables and enter them and look
there's no doubt I think that um the the
tragedy of the human situation is that
we are these exquisite sensitive
thoughtful artists and poets you know
who have the capacity to imagine so much
and to dream so much and either a we
don't have the opportunity to express
that beauty that ecstasy that yearning
because of economic reasons but also
because of physiological reasons you
know maybe maybe you know you had to
work most of your life and then you got
an illness you know when you were 25 you
studied philosophy and that it really
puts you into a point of where you were
at when you were in your 20s and other
people don't study philosophy and
they're working lots of jobs and and so
that also makes potentially less
creative beings yes I mean I studied
philosophy because it was I was lucky I
had a mother who was an artist who kind
of encouraged me to do what I loved I'm
aware that that's a privilege for sure
yeah the more that we can mold these
minds into the world to understand what
you're teaching right now about that
essential bummer I think more people
will seek that creative unleashing into
the world I hope so